vince is with us in Phoenix hi Vince
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
doing Dave first-time caller longtime
listener well thank you sir how can we
help so much I've been a depo and I've
been trying to get myself out of it okay
I've got three loans basically vehicle
loans stupidity is what got me there and
then trying to basically trying to get
myself out of debt I went to kind of I
got a 2016 Chevy Silverado took it down
to a car dealership they gave me a price
not much what I was asking for but you
know try to do it that way so I went to
a bank see if I can get a difference in
the loan to get it paid off to make
payment to the bank instead the banks
won't touch me because of my credit yeah
bad crime I'll be I'm basically just
trying to get out of debt I'm trying I'm
basically just trying to get rid of them
brand-new truck so let's stop it stop a
saying so the car the Chevy Silverado
let's start with that one what is it
worth okay they got it priced at 24,000
the dealer the dealer okay that's not
what it's worth that's wholesale then
yeah that's that's what they offered me
so you need a little you need to look up
on Kelly Blue Book what the car is worth
because you probably need to sell it
instead of selling it to a dealer I'm
gonna guess and say it's worth 27 or 28
if the dealer offered you 24 because
they're buying it at wholesale to resell
it to make a profit there's nothing evil
about that but they're buying the car
cheap it's what they do so what do you
owe on the Silverado 32 okay so let's
pretend you could sell it for 27 and
it's worth 32 then you'd need 5,000 and
you've already figured out you can't
borrow that cuz your credits bad what do
you make a year
I make between fifty and sixty thousand
a year especially alright and you're
single
that does she work outside the home
that's my that's my other problem I'm
kind of help pay her that's two one of
those she works are you married work yes
okay so they're your dance all right and
so maybe that's does she make
she makes probably about thirty to
thirty three thousand a year okay all
right so we've got we got a $90,000
household income that you need to save
up five thousand dollars in order to get
the Silverado sold now the next car what
is it at the 2018 Chevy Trax okay and
what do you owe on it
thirty-two okay and what is it worth and
now I didn't even look it up but I try
to refinance it they told me it was uh
was about 9 grand over whatever they
were asking for
okay that's loan value again that's not
what it's worth and so I same situation
there it sounds like that's going to be
worth probably in the twenty five or
twenty four range when you look it up on
Kelly Blue Book you need to go to
kbb.com and look these up on private
sale what's the next vehicle okay and
what do you owe on it
eight thousand okay and what is it worth
sixty seven hundred who said I took it
to one of those a harley-davidson riding
one of the right now places well right
now owns harley-davidson uh yeah okay
but but bottom line is is again they're
trying you're trying to sell these cars
at wholesale so that car that Harley's
probably if you were to put it in the
newspaper put it on Craigslist it's
probably worth about what you owe on it
yeah that up and figure out what it's
worth and get it sold and then let's
figure out which of the other two cars
we're going to sell first when we save
up $5,000
and you can get yourself on a tight
budget beans and rice rice and beans you
need to start selling everything in
sight that you can get your hands on and
clear yourself out of these cars you are
freaking carp or this is a ridiculous
situation with your cars and you've got
to get said of all three of these
vehicles I agree with you your
conclusion on that but it's probably
gonna take you a year